Let's do a couple of word
problems. This tells us that
Nadia's at home and Peter is
at school, which is 6 miles
away from home.
So let me draw a little
diagram here.
So Nadia is there.
Peter is over there, and
they're 6 miles apart.
So this is the distance between
home and school.
That is 6 miles.
They start traveling to each
other at the same time.
So they both leave at the
same time, traveling
towards each other.
Nadia is walking at 3 and
1/2 miles per hour.
So she's travelling at
3 and 1/2 miles per
hour in that direction.
And Peter is skateboarding
at 6 miles per
hour in that direction.
So Peter is going in that
direction at 6 miles per hour.
When will they meet and
how far from home is
their meeting place?
So let's say that their meeting
place is right-- I
don't know.
It's going to be closer to
home, because this guy is
going faster.
Peter is going faster.
So let's say, let x be
equal to the distance
from home they meet.
So this distance right here
is going to be x.
And then what's this distance
going to be?
Well, if that's x, and this
whole thing is 6 miles, then
this distance right there is
going to be 6 minus x.
So Nadia will travel x
miles and Peter will
travel 6 minus x miles.
And they're going to travel
the same amount of time.
Remember, they both leave at
time 0, and after time t, they
will both meet right there.
So they're both going to take
the same amount of time.
So Nadia's equation, if we just
remember that distance is
equal to rate times time, we
could use that for both of
them, in Nadia's case, the
distance she travels is x.
x is going to be equal to her
rate, which is 3.5 miles per
hour, times t, which is the
time that she travels.
And then Peter's equation is
going to be his distance.
Well, he travels 6 minus x
miles, so it's 6 minus x is
going to be equal to his rate,
which is 6 miles per hour
times the time he travels.
Well, he also travels
t hours, so times t.
So we have two equations
and two unknowns, so we
can solve for them.
We've already solved
for x here.
So let's substitute this
for x right there.
So we can rewrite this equation
as 6 minus, but
instead of an x, we can put
3.5t, 6 minus 3.5t, because we
know that x is equal to
3.5t, is equal to 6t.
And then let's see, if we add
3.5t to both sides of this
equation, we get 6 is equal to
3.5t plus 6t is 9.5t, or if we
divide both sides by 9.5, you
get t is equal to 6 over 9.5
hours, which is a bit
of a bizarre number.
But 9.5, we can rewrite that.
That is the same thing as 6
over-- see, 9.5, that's the
same thing as 19/2, right?
19/2, you divide that and
you would get 9.5.
So this is equal to
6 times 2 over 19.
12/19 of an hour.
That's how long it'll
take them to meet.
And then if you ask the question
how far from home
will they meet?
If you want to figure out the
x value, x is going to be
equal to 3.5-- actually, instead
of writing 3.5, I can
write 3.5 as 7/2; that's the
same thing as 3.5-- times our
time, times 12/19.
So you divide the numerator and
the denominator by 2, and
we get 7 times 6 is
42 over 19 miles.
And this right here,
that is in hours.
So in 12/19 of an hour-- it's
a weird fraction-- they will
meet exactly 42/19
miles from home.
So it's a little over
2 miles from home.
Next problem.
Peter bought several notebooks
at Staples for $2.25.
And he bought a few
more notebooks at
Rite Aid for $2 each.
He spent the same amount of
money in both places and he
bought 17 notebooks in total.
How many notebooks did
he buy in each store?
So let's define some
variables.
Let's let S equal number
bought at Staples.
And then we could say that R is
equal to the number bought
at Rite Aid.
So what do we know?
So he bought a total
of 17 notebooks.
Let me do that in a
different color.
He bought a total
of 17 notebooks.
So that tells us that S
plus R is equal to 17.
And we also know that he spent
the same amount of money in
both places.
So how much did he spend
at Rite Aid?
Let me do this in orange.
Spent the same amount of
money in both places.
So at Staples, how much
did he spend?
He bought S notebooks for $2.25
each, so 2.25S, that's
how much he spent at Staples.
That's going to be equal
to the amount he
spent at Rite Aid.
He spent $2 per notebook
at Rite Aid.
So $2 times the number of
notebooks from Rite Aid, so
this is spent at Rite Aid.
So once again, two equations
with two unknowns.
We can do a little bit of
substitution maybe.
So what's the best way
to substitute here?
Well, let's divide both
sides of this
equation by 2 right here.
So you have-- I'm going to
rewrite 2.2-- well, I'll just
do it like this.
So you have R.
If you divide both sides of this
by 2, you have 2.25 over
2S is equal to R, right?
I just divided both sides
of this by 2.
So if you take this value and
you substitute it in for R
right there, this equation
becomes S plus-- instead of an
R we have 2.25 over
2S is equal to 17.
And let's just simplify.
So this is 1-- we could view
this as 2 over 2S, right?
The coefficient there
is just 1.
So we can view this as we have
a common denominator.
This is the same thing is 4.25
over 2S is equal to 17.
I'm avoiding doing any
hard math just yet.
Let me multiply both sides
by the inverse.
2/4.25.
It's a little bizarre to have
an expression with both a
fraction and a decimal,
but it's not illegal.
Let's multiply both
times 2/4.25.
These cancel out, and so you get
S is equal to 17 times 2
is 34 over 4.25.
And actually, I can
eyeball that.
That looks like that should
be equal to 8, right?
4.25 is 4 and 1/4, which is the
same thing as 17/4 over 4.
So this is the same thing as
34 over 17/4, which is the
same thing as 34 times 4/17.
Put a 1 there, divide by 17, you
get a 2, divide by 17, you
get a 1, 2 times 4 is 8.
So he bought 8 notebooks at
Staples, this is 8, and then
at Rite Aid, he bought-- well,
8 plus R is equal to 17.
Subtract 8 from both sides.
He must have bought 9 notebooks
at Rite Aid.
Let's do one more.
This one is especially
fun-looking.
Peter is outside, looking
at the pigs and
chickens in the yard.
Nadia is indoors and cannot
see the animals.
Peter gives her a puzzle.
He tells her that he counts 13
heads and 36 feet and asks her
how many pigs and how many
chickens are in the yard.
So let's once again define
our variables.
P is equal to the
number of pigs.
And let C is equal to the
number of chickens.
So the number of heads will
essentially be the number of
pigs and chickens, assuming
they each have one head.
So the number of pigs plus the
number of chickens will be
equal to the number of heads,
so that is right here.
That is 13 heads.
And then 4 times the number
of pigs, right?
Each pig has 4 legs, so 4 times
the number of pigs plus
2 times the number of chickens,
assuming we're
dealing with two-legged
chickens, is going to be equal
to the number of feet,
is equal to 36.
So once again, we have two
equations with two unknowns.
Instead of solving it with
substitution, I'm going to do
it by adding and subtracting
the two equations.
So what we can do, this
equation, we can
multiply it times 2.
And when I say multiply it times
2, we have to multiply
the entire equation times 2.
And so it's still true.
So we multiply the entire
equation times 2.
This becomes 2P plus
2C is equal to 26.
And now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to subtract this
equation from that equation,
which you can do.
Because that is equal to that,
that is equal to that, and so
we're not doing anything that
violates the laws of algebra.
So if you subtract the bottom
equation from the top
equation, or I could just put
a negative sign everywhere
here, just so you know
we're subtracting,
4P minus 2P is 2P.
2C minus 2C is 0.
That's why I did this, so that
these would cancel out.
And then 36 minus 26
is equal to 10.
So 2P is equal to 10.
Divide both sides by 2.
We have 5 pigs.
And then 5 plus the number of
chickens is equal to 13, so we
must have-- subtract 5 from
both sides-- 8 chickens.
Now if this confuses you, you
might want to try it with
substitution, but I have many
videos on solving systems of
equations where I go a little
bit slower and explain a
little bit more of
the logic of it.
So whatever floats your boat.
But either way, Nadia should
hopefully guess or hopefully
solve for 5 pigs
and 8 chickens.
And it should work out, right?
You have 13 animals.
You have 13 heads.
And if you multiply 5 times 4,
that's 20 pig feet plus 16
chicken feet.
20 plus 16 is 36 total feet.